all right so a few days ago like a week
ago I saw a trailer for Cloud Atlas and
now that it's a week later I've come to
one conclusion and that is I won't
actually know what the movies about
until I watch it seriously if this
trailer is awesome but you just don't
know what it's about
really our lives and our choices each
encounter Luisa Rey spyglass magazine
right suggest a new potential direction
it's written and directed by the
Wachowski z-- and the director of Run
Lola Run and what Chomsky thing kind of
asked me like because I love the first
matrix I love the first matrix that's it
from them Ln the end of Speed Racer I
like the end of speed race if that last
race that's actually badass but you got
to give it up to this trailer for one
thing and that is the trailer is
intriguing a phenomenon that
determined the course of our lives
these forces begin long before we are
born and continue that
Parrish it takes place in the past
present and future Tom Hanks is in it
you know so that's legit but then you
see actors in like the present timeframe
that are actually in the future also you
see the dude from 21 in this ship you're
like all right clearly the past and you
see the present and you see the future
this futuristic awesome looking future
you know like neon Knight Riders from
turtles in time then you see the
post-apocalyptic crazy future didn't you
notice Halle Berry and Tom Hanks are in
the present but they're also in that
future you're like mm-hmm
what didn't you start to listen to the
trailer and see things and you start
theorizing that's all I can do at this
point I can just theorize as to what the
movies about if a trailer makes me do
that immediately I'm like this trailer
is awesome but in listening to the
trailer and watching the trailer starts
talking about how things from the past
are connected to the present and they're
also tied into the future so I'm like oh
awesome it's one of those everything's
connected kind of stories you know I
love that and the fact that the
actors play the same roles makes me
think it might have something to do with
reincarnation maybe Oh movement I wrote
imagining us meeting again and again in
different dives different ages you know
people find each other in the past they
form connections in the present somehow
they find each other again the things
that happen in the past feed into the
present I don't know for sure
I know people out there have read the
book they're like this jackoff has no
idea what he's talking about that's
quite possible but since I just
ironically addressed that I think I'm
safe probably not though it is the
Internet
the movie could be a piece of for
all I know it could be poorly executed
poorly written I mean anything's
possible really but right now as it
stands the trailer itself is one of the
most intriguing trailers I've seen in
years
seriously I was at a friend's wedding
and the whole time the weddings going on
they're up there in their holes and
hands I'm just like all right so Cloud
Atlas I think it might have something to
do with people's souls living on finding
each other making connections from the
past that I really just don't know
though I mean it's hard to say this one
that's me thinking
just kidding Kim if you're watching this
nice wedding and I'm just joking if
she's not watching this seriously it was
like that
but awesome visuals great music in the
trailer you watch the trailer you're
just thinking about it all the time
you're theorizing given though and not
knowing what the movies about it's
nothing that one trip to Wikipedia can't
cure but I don't want to do that I like
not knowing what the movies about I want
to go into this movie being like I don't
know what I'm in for but I want to watch
it so Cloud Atlas have you seen the
trailer what did you think of it this is
a trailer we're talking about here
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more